well you know I think it's a very
interesting question I don't really know
the answer to how you construct yourself
I think I remember when I was a little
girl I was about 7 or 8 and I had
realized that I had not been myself in
my own head for so long that I didn't
remember what my own voice sounded like
in my head because I was always playing
in my head so then I thought where's my
voice and I had to actually invent my
own voice I had to make it up because I
didn't have a thinking voice you realize
that you just take for granted that you
have a thinking voice you think I'm
going to you know I'm going to go get a
cup of coffee I'd really love to do this
and make what happens if that's for some
reason missing and that in my case was
true I didn't have a voice for a while
there and I and I had to I remember for
quite a long time I remember kind of
panic coming over me and then saying
okay I have to I have to make this
person off it and maybe that's who I
maybe that's me I don't know I don't
know
of course yes I'm sure it has I'm sure
it has shifted with experience
absolutely and you know there's no I
don't know if there's any way of
cataloging or kind of recording your
inner voice you know so that you can
think how did I think when I was 21 but
partly what the book is about is how in
a way the book is kind of constructed on
an architecture of twin betrayals that's
the architecture of the book and in a
way a woman of 50 is looking back at her
young 20 self and seeing a woman who
betrayed somebody and actually caused
them something terrible to happen
through a betrayal a love a betrayal of
love and then that same you know that
same woman is then the same thing
happens to her she is betrayed so it's
like looking looking but she's looking
like across the void at her younger self
who has a completely different way of
thinking morally certainly but also just
her her attitude toward the world and
yet there's an essence a sort of essence
of Pippa that I think is consistent and
I do think that we have some essence I
do think there's an essence whatever
that is whether that that's a that's a
fundamental character trait I don't know
if you know you could say that you know
if you want to call it a soul or a you
know some sort of essential self that
that remains you know static or not
static but remains I think in a person
no I don't think so I don't think you
can get be objective with memory
I think memory is a creative act in a
way and very unreliable and um yeah I
mean I think that you know memory is
very influenced by our unconscious as is
you know Dan Daly waking life you know I
think that we are dreaming in you know
part of our mind is kind of playing
another movie behind you know our eyes
as we're watching so that's what makes
it so complicated just to walk around
because you know you have all these
different realities shifting through
yourself all the time and you're trying
to believe that you're just walking down
the hall you know and get to down to the
baby that's just me
it's an interesting question because
last night I went to see the seagull
which is a play that's all about I think
art as a disease I mean being an artist
is being having a disease and that's why
there's a doctor on set they really need
one and you know and it's about how it's
infectious and it ruins people and it's
really interesting because I felt this
for a long time that it's like a virus
that people get and then they never
recover
sadly I really do I mean that was all I
was ever good for was making things that
apart from myself and you know again
that's one of the reasons I you know
love PIPA so much is that she doesn't
have that compulsion she is it does she
doesn't have a compulsion to make
something outside of herself she she is
what she is completely hers she is her
own art in a sense but she doesn't need
to make art and that I envy her that in
a way and I think that's one of the most
interesting things about her to me